alert a step in the wrong direction Los
Angeles County will soon require Mass
indoors even for those who are
vaccinated thank you for joining us at
five I'm Brian Loftus and I'm Denise
Valdez the mass mandate will be
reinstated and that's going to start on
Saturday but the big question is will
Nevada follow Sasha Loftus live tonight
with more details Sasha
today's and Bryant we've seen quite a
few people arriving here at the Las
Vegas sign for the last few hours it's
still pretty crowded here and we spoke
to a lot of visitors some say they're
concerned about this recent rise in
numbers While others are choosing to
mask up again today Los Angeles County's
help the officers said those living in
California should reconsider travel to
states with increasingly High rates of
covet transmission that includes Nevada
our state positive positivity rate has
climbed to 10.7 percent with nearly 95
percent of cases coming from here in
southern Nevada now LA county is also
re-implementing its mass mandate indoors
as you mentioned regardless of
vaccination status now I spoke with UNLV
Medical School directors medical school
dean rather Dr Mark Khan about why we're
seeing this uptick
and it is concerning
um really this is because people are
starting to let down their guard and get
together and the the group that's most
concerning are the unvaccinated so when
we look at Patients hospitalized with
covid-19 nearly a hundred percent in
fact 99.8 percent of them have not been
vaccinated
now at this time there are no plans to
reinstate Mass mandates here in Nevada
though Mass are still recommended
indoors and Outdoors if you are not
vaccinated now back out here live as of
today 46 of those eligible are fully
vaccinated here in Nevada that is well
below many other states across the U.S
reporting live tonight's Auto Loftus 8
News Now